- Skydiving in Dubai is spectacular,
it's unlike any other place I've skydived.
Once I'm in the sky,
it's just like I'm like anyone else.
(bright electronic music)
My name's Jarett Martin.
I'm 26 years old.
I'm from Seattle, Washington,
and I'm a skydiver.
My family's history is all skydiving.
My grandfather was a skydiver,
which led to my father being a skydiver.
Then my sisters made a skydive.
And my aunts and uncles are all skydivers.
Of course, naturally myself.
Skydiving runs in the family.
Well I've been skydiving
for over 10 years now.
I did my first skydive
with my father at age nine.
And then I started on my
solo career at age 15.
And I've been loving skydiving ever since.
I've been disabled for eight years.
I was in a weird parachuting accident
when I was 18 years old.
And it was a tragic accident,
but I think in the end it
really made me stronger,
and maybe even a better person, who knows.
When I was injured,
what really saved me was
the family-like attributes
that skydiving has with each other.
And there was no time
for me to be depressed.
There was no time for me to be sad.
My friends and family really
made it an easy transition
to what would be the
next chapter of my life.
I first moved to Dubai in 2013.
I developed some interest
from Skydive Dubai
and I got the opportunity
to come out here full time.
It's quite a production for me to skydive.
I mean, the skydive itself of
falling out of an airplane,
that's easy, but it's all of the things
that lead up to getting in the airplane
and, you know, getting back in my wheelchair,
I couldn't do it without my friends.
And they're absolutely incredible.
(atmospheric music)
The views from the
height that we jump from,
you can see everything.
It's one of those things,
you just have to try it.
It's indescribable.
(uptempo electronic music)
There's been a couple of adaptations
of equipment that I've had to use
for me to be able to skydive.
And one of them is my
leg retention device.
It keeps my legs separated,
yet it keeps them from
flapping wildly out of control.
The landing is one of the most-asked
questions that I get.
I can't stand up my landings,
like most able-bodied skydivers,
so I just kind of do a glorified
tuck and roll essentially.
It's as graceful of a
landing as you can get.
I have probably about
close to 5,000 jumps total.
And the freedom of being able
to repeat skydive after skydive
while I've been in Dubai,
really racked up the
jump numbers quite fast.
When I'm in the zone,
and I'm like really like doing my thing,
it's nice to know that there's people
that I'm helping,
whether it be disabled people
trying to get them to do
whatever they think they can do.
Because if I can do skydiving,
anybody can do anything.
And whether it be someone disabled or not,
I think it inspires
everyone to push themselves
to do things that they
never thought was possible.
If you think about it,
like it's some guy in
a wheelchair skydiving.
That doesn't seem possible.